vous savez que nous là l'émission on
aime ça les produits révolutionnaires et
il paraît que ça c'en est un aussi
efficace que du savon à lessive et ça
dure jusqu'à quatre ans merveilleux il
est une chose à faire tester le produit
pour voir si tout ça est vrai
[Musique]
on est une famille de quatre j'ai un
conjoint et j'ai douze enfants on
apprend que c'est qu'un enfant qu'il ya
là
je suis en plein milieu d'un processus
de propreté avec le bd je me couche tard
à mme drai que je fais dit la rage à
temps plein
marie-josée bergeron est une mer très
active qui aime quand ça bouge et il est
bien servi
arthur c'est un garçon qui débordent
d'imagination filer au cm c'est une
petite bombe d'énergie donc oui c'est la
tornade mais une des leurs mains
depuis plusieurs années la famille
essaie de contribuer à la protection de
l'environnement ce qui inclut des petits
gestes pour mieux consommer nos produits
nettoyants sont bio on essayait
d'arrêter d'acheter des immeubles dont
on en excès est réutilisable marie-josée
veut aussi changer ses habitudes de
lavage en naviguant sur internet elle
est attirée par un produit
révolutionnaire les gargouilles
ça c'est une gargouille une balle zéro
déchet qui peut remplacer n'importe quel
des personnes une gargouille c'est une
sphère de plastique qui contient des
petites billes en céramique
selon l'entreprise elles aident à
protéger l'environnement et les gros
contenants comme ça c'est 50 millions
tonnes de déchets plastiques par année
je veux passer pour la mère de mes
enfants pour la vienne
les gargouilles c'est aussi une
entreprise française très visible sur
les réseaux sociaux en deux ans elle a
dépensé près d'un million et demi de
dollars en publicité sur facebook dont
certaines sont adaptées au public
canadien les gares go il remplace
complètement la lessive je n'ai qu'à les
mettre directement dans ma machine avec
les vêtements moi je t avais vraiment
fasciné par ce petit medley voyons qui
est concerné peu savent
tout d'un coup ça tombe du ciel puis
mais quelle invention révolutionnaire
marie-josée commandes 10 gargouille pour
elle et pour en offrir un cadeau c'était
au tour de 160 dollars pour dix balles
ça choque ça prend trois balles pour une
petite brassée 5 pour une grosse avant
même de les avoir reçu ses proches la
met en garde ce qu'ils incitent à faire
plus de recherche j'étais pas en mesure
de trouver autre chose que des sites
d'opinion des blogs des sites de mamar
des choses comme ce qu'ils disent
quel est le produit fonctionne pas donc
pour moi c'est insuffisant
notre mission découvrir si oui ou non
les gargouilles peuvent remplacer le
détergent à lessive pour nous aider nous
faisons appel à l'ingénieur guettant
piedallu son équipe va comparer trois
types de lavage à l'eau seulement avec
du détergent thé avec des gargouilles on
a des bandelettes de tissu qui sont
celles de façon très standard au départ
les bandelettes sont toutes blanches
ensuite chaque carré de tissu est
complètement enduit de substances
différentes donc si on a le cash de 20
le lait au chocolat le sait le noir de
carbone avec huile minérale et le sébum
avec pigments la dernière ici est
potache et c'est ce qu'on considère
quand le bla
un technicien coup les bandelettes sur
des serviettes
chaque bras c contient la même quantité
de tissu est réglé à la même température
le temps de faire une douzaine de cycle
de lavage nous en profitons pour voir si
les explications des gargouilles sont
scientifiquement fondées
chaque gargouille contient 150 petites
billes en pis aux céramiques qui
agissent naturellement sur le ph de
louvre en remuant elle crée une mousse
d'eau alcalines naturel sans aucun
produit chimique qui nettoie toutes
sortes de tâches les fameuses bd
céramique qui change le ph de l'eau est
ce que c'est de la magie c'est je vais
comme kate qui est ce qu'un chimiste
part à rire puis nous dit que il ya
vraiment juste qu'il faut qu'ils peuvent
france
pour y répondre nous allons rencontrer
john tavares il est professeur titulaire
au département de génie chimique à
polytechnique montréal si on a
moindrement des tâches contiennent des
protéines par exemple
certains aliments sont adulés des taches
grasses ça prend un détergent pour nous
élever si on avait une eau très alcaline
on peut faire ce qu'on appelle la
réaction de saponification mais c'est la
réaction pour faire du savon justin tv
reste à mesurer le ph de l'eau en
contact avec une gargouille
résultat le ph augmente mais pas assez
pour créer du savon avec les niveaux que
vous aviez calculer est-ce que ça change
quelque chose ça ne devrait pas fabre
d'impact substantiel
des gargouilles offre une autre
explication les billes en céramique vont
restructurer les molécules d'eau pour
qu'elle soit mieux absorbée par les
tissus nous allons tester voici une
simple goutte d'eau elle a une forme
bombée qui se tient bien et voici une
goutte d'eau mélangée à du détergent à
lessive qui rend l'eau plus liquide le
détergent le savons et réduit la tension
de l'eau et ça serait pas mieux ça sahel
pour mieux pénétrer dans les tissus on
peut également regarder si une roue dans
laquelle aurait trahi une gargouille
aurait cet effet le résultat la goutte
d'eau garde sa forme l'eau avec une
gargouille conserve la même tension de
surface que l'os sans gargouille
contrairement à l'eau savonneuse
troisième argument l'action mécanique de
la gargouille qui se frotte contre les
vêtements
de rajouter 3 gargouille selon vous
est-ce que ça un pouvoir des tâches
avec l'aspect mécanique la chance non
pourquoi pas de manière significative
nous avons contacté les responsables des
gargouilles et les refuse de nous
accorder une entrevue à la caméra dans
leur réponse par courriel aucune étude
scientifique n'a compagne leurs
explications il nous dirigent plutôt
vers un test d' usage de performance et
d'efficacité auprès de 65 consommatrices
française les conclusions de ce test les
gargouilles une solution de lavage plus
efficace que le lavage à l'eau claire
quand on cherche des chiffres quand on
cherchait des des études de référence
une note en bas de page un lien
cliquable un journal scientifique on
n'en trouve pas
de retour chez politest les cycles de
lavage sont terminés le technicien
mesure l'intensité des tâches à l'aide
d'un lecteur optique et il calcule la
moyenne on détermine taux d'efficacité
de lavage un lavage parfait ça serait
quoi un lavage parfait en obtiendrait
son premier résultat le détergent à
lessive qui détachent les vêtements à
82,4 % deuxième résultat un lavage à
l'eau claire ça peut paraître surprenant
mais l'eau à elle seule la plaie
vêtements à 75% même sans savon et les
gargouilles
avant de vous donner les résultats nous
allons demander à marie josée de
comparer les bandelettes à l'oeil nu ce
qu'on est ici c'est un lavage à l'eau ça
c'est de l'eau le patron de l'opa de
savon
ça c'est le jargon
mais voyons les héros différence
salariés la bandelette la vie avec du
savon à lessive visiblement plus propre
que les deux autres mais ces ide ans et
que je veux dire je laval où la voyons
dont oh la la la la la la quel piège
résultat les gargouilles sont efficaces
à 75,9 %
points 9
c'est très chaque payer pour points 9
d'efficacité
est ce qu'on peut considérer que des
vêtements la vie avec une des berguois
vont sortir propre de la laveuse
j'aurais aimé te dire qu'ils vont sortir
aussi pop qu'avec de l'eau près d'un
pour cent de différentes donc de
l'intérieur de la marge d'erreur avec
l'eau est ce que ça vous surprend ses
résultats non ça ne me surprend pas je
vois pas de de potentiel de nettoyage et
c'est ce que vous avez besoin les
responsables des gargouilles nous
écrivent même si le résultat du
nettoyage n'a pas un écart énorme dans
votre étude il y a tout de même un écart
et les clients remarque bien la
différence ce que votre client vous
remarqué mais non mais non mais non les
clients remarque que leurs vêtements
sont lavés parce que visiblement l'os à
l'avs c'est tout sachant cela qu'est ce
que vous allez faire des gargouilles mai
mais elle montre juges des jeux en ligne
dans la rue c'était leur dernière
journée dans la salle de bain
[Musique]
donc les gargouilles se vante de
protéger la planète alors que dans les
faits l'entreprise vous envoie un bidule
en plastique qui ne sert strictement à
rien à 0,9 pour cent bret avez vous
remarqué que les produits miracles se
donne souvent des allures scientifique
c'est ça le problème parce que pour le
consommateur c'est difficile de faire un
test comme ce que vous avez vu dans le
reportage alors c'est triste à dire mais
il faut rester méfiant